jude was curious if the automated
machine at his restaurant was filling
drinks with the proper amount
he filled a sample of 20 drinks to test
his null hypothesis which is the actual
population mean for how much drink there
was in in the drinks per drink is 530
milliliters versus his alternative
hypothesis is that the population mean
is not 530 milliliters where mu is the
mean filling amount
the drinks in the sample contained a
mean amount of 528 milliliters with a
standard deviation of 4 milliliters
these results produced a test statistic
of t is equal to negative 2.236
and a p-value of approximately 0.038
assuming the conditions for inference
were met what is an appropriate
conclusion at the alpha equals 0.05
significance level and they give us some
choices here and like always i encourage
you to pause this video and see if you
can figure it out on your own
all right so now let's work through this
together so let's just remind ourselves
what's going on so you have some
population of drinks and we care about
the true population mean you have a null
hypothesis around it that the true mean
is 530 milliliters but then there's the
alternative hypothesis that it's not 530
milliliters so to test your null
hypothesis you take a sample in this
case we had a sample of
20 drinks and using that sample you
calculate a sample mean and then you
also calculate a sample standard
deviation they tell us these things
right over here and then using this
information and actually our sample size
you are able to calculate a t statistic
you're able to calculate a t-statistic
and then using that t-statistic you are
able to calculate a p-value and the
p-value is what is the probability of
getting a result at least this extreme
if we assume that the null hypothesis is
true and if that probability is lower
than our significance level then we say
hey that's a very low probability we're
going to reject our null hypothesis
which would suggest our alternative so
the key to this question is just to
compare this p-value right over here to
our significance level and as we see the
p-value
0.038 is indeed
less than 0.05
and so because of this we would reject
the null hypothesis
we would reject the null hypothesis
which would suggest the alternative that
the true mean is something different
than 530 milliliters
and so if we look at our choices here
so the first choice says reject the null
hypothesis this is strong evidence that
the mean filling amount is different
than 530 milliliters yeah that one looks
good we this suggests
this is strong evidence this suggests
the alternative hypothesis which is that
right over there let's read the other
ones just make sure that they don't make
sense so this is rejecting the null
hypothesis that looks true so far
this isn't enough evidence to conclude
that the mean filling amount is
different than 530 milliliters no not
not the first one is definitely much
stronger
fail to reject the null hypothesis no we
are rejecting the null hypothesis
because our p value is lower than our
significance level fail to reject now
we'd rule that one out as well